[Music]
this evening we introduce you to a young
man who wants to make history
senior political correspondent mike
emanuel has his story tonight
madison cawthorne is aiming to become
the youngest person elected to congress
since the late 1700s the first move was
to defeat his opponent
in the north carolina primary which he
did overwhelmingly
the second is pretty easy he will be
legally old enough to serve when he
turns 25
on august 1st president trump and the
man who sidi could be filling chief of
staff mark meadows
actually backed hawthorne's primary
opponent
but tuesday at the president's
invitation hawthorne brought his family
to the white house
it was definitely not a referendum on
trump with that endorsement and so
he he was very aware of that today and
he was very excited to get to work with
us in the future
cawthorne also had a chance encounter
with the president senator lindsey
graham and rudy giuliani while visiting
the trump international hotel
i got big shoes to fill right here she's
also making the rounds with leading
republicans
like gop whip steve scalise they were
impressed with the way we've been
running our campaign so they want us to
keep doing what we were doing
as a member of gen z qawthorn says the
republican party
is struggling to reach his peers they
are not able to connect with this
this generational time bomb they're not
they've tried to defuse it but they're
unable to
i'm a millennial he says he can speak to
young voters and will be helpful to the
gop
we don't want government telling us what
to do we don't want these high tax rates
we just want to be able to live our
lives and that resonates with everyone
i asked cawthorne about the recent
confederate names
and statue issues that's not something
to be decided by an angry mob
if we want to take down statues of
imperfect people we have to take them
all down
some of cawthorne's maturity likely
comes from the fact he was nearly
killed in a car accident six years ago
when i was 19 years old
i exited the hospital with over three
million dollars in medical debt
clawthorne believes he's here for a
reason i still have the ability to make
a difference the lord decided to protect
my mind protect my ability to speak
and through that accident and now i've
got this motivation this passion
this zeal to realize that our life can
be taken from us at any moment
in washington mike emanuel fox news